في الوقت الذي يعتقد الجميع ان كوفد 19 قد
اصبح من الماضي ها هي لجنه الصحه الوطنيه
الصينيه تاكد تسجيل حالتي وفاه جديدين
بسبب الاصابه بفيروس كورونا في العاصمه
بيجن تاتي هذه الحصيله ضمن موجه المتوقعه
من الاصابات بالفيروس بعد تخفيف السلطات
اجراءتها الراميه للقضاء على الفيروس
وكانت لجنه الصحه قد ابلغت عن نحو الفي
اصابه جديده امس بفارق اقل من نحو 200
حالته مقارنه بيوم السبت وفي مدينه شنغهاي
طلبت السلطات من المؤسسات التعليميه اعطاء
الدروس عن بعد ارتفاع حالات الاصابه
بكرونا وسيتم اغلاق ودور الحضانه ومراكز
رعايه الاطفال اعتبارا من اليوم
ومعنى الان من بيجين مدير مكتبنا ناصر عبد
الحق ناصر كانت هناك كثير من التظاهرات
الشعبيه التي خرجت تعبيرا عن رفضها لسياسه
صفر كوفد التي اعتمدتها الصين ولكن ها نحن
نناقش عوده التدريس عن بعد من جديد
طف لنا الاجواء ودرجه القلق الان في الصين
في مدينه شنغهاي جاء بقرار محلي في
المدينه حيث كثرت او زادت الاعداد خلال
الايام الماضيه منذ
رفعت الصين معظم القيود التي كانت مفروضه
للسيطره على الوباء خاصه تلك المتعلقه
بفحص او اختبار فيروس كورونا وايضا ااه
الكود الصحي للمواطنين وبالتالي انتشار
الفيروس مجددا كان متوقعا سواء من السلطات
الصينيه او حتى من المواطنين همم انفسهم
ومعظم المواطنين يقولون بانه على الرغم من
عدد الاصابات الحالي فانهم لا يزالوا
يفضلون اوسعيدون برفع السلطات لتلك القيود
التي اثقلت او كانت ثقي على كاهليهم واثرت
بشكل مباشر خلال السنوات الماضيه على
حياتهم الطبيعيه في ما يتعلق بعوده همم
الدروس عبر الانترنت في المدارس في مدينه
شنغهاي منذ ان رفعت الصين القيود عن فيروس
كورونا قبل اا اسبوعين او ما يزيد عن ذلك
قالت بان همم لا يوجد هناك لم تفرض قوانين
جديده على المدارس لكي تكون عبر الانترنت
وتركت الامر
للحكومات المحليه والمدارس بحد ذاتها لكي
تقرر فيما اذا كانت ستعطي الدروس همم عبر
مقاعد الدراسه او عبر الانترنت وكان معظم
المدارس في الصين قد اختارت خلال الفتره
الماضيه ان تستمر في تقديم هذه الدروس عبر
الانترنت لكن يبدو ان مدينه شنغهاي همم
كانت قررت غير ذلك همم مع بدي برافع
القيود ولكن بعد ان شعرت بانتشار الوفاء
بشكل سريع قررت اعاده اغلاق المدارس
واستئناف التدريس همم عن بعد ايضا ليله
الصينيون يترقبون انتشار هذا الفيروس خاصه
مع اقتراب عطله راس السنه الصينيه وما
يطلق عليها بعيد الربيع والتي ستاتي في
منتصف الشهر القادم وهذه اكبر يتم في خلال
هذه همم العطله همم اكبر هجره جماعيه على
مستوى العالم حيث يقوم همم الملايين من
الصينيين بالعوده الى مسقط راسهم
للقاء ذويهم لكن هناك توقعات بان لا يكون
همم تكون عمليات همم السفر بهذا الحجم
الكبير خلال الفتره الحاليه تحسبا من
انتشار الفيروس بشكل
تكاد تكون الشوارع خاليه من المواطنين فمن
لم يصبه الموت هنا هو مقيم داخل بيته
تحسبا للاصابه به على هذه المعلومات ناصر
عبد الحق من بيجين شكرا